[Música]
la organización panamericana de la salud
afirmó que sudamérica es la región más
preocupante por el aumento de casos de
kobe 19 la ms explicó que en casi todos
los países sudamericanos se han
incrementado los contagios y que la
mitad de las muertes por el brote que ha
habido en todo el mundo durante la
última semana ocurrieron en ese
continente
pero am bretaña protesta ante lo que
calificó como la toma de la embajada
birmana en londres por parte del
agregado militar de la junta golpista
manifestantes se congregaron a las
afueras de la embajada hermana en
londres el miércoles cuando se hizo
público que el embajador no podía entrar
el parlamento francés debate una
propuesta de ley sobre la eutanasia que
pretende establecer el derecho a un
final de vida libre y electivo los
diputados de la oposición han presentado
unas 3.000 enmiendas para intentar
bloquear el proyecto este supone un
debate álgido en este país
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 serrado blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos con los contagios de koi 19
que se disparan en casi todos los países
del continente americano la situación de
américa del sur preocupa particularmente
a la organización panamericana de la
salud argentino y brasil están entre los
10 países con más nuevos contagios
diarios del mundo ambos se registraron
récords históricos de infecciones y de
víctimas mortales pero mientras el
gobierno argentino decidió imponer
nuevas restricciones del brasileño sigue
negándose a tomar cualquier medida de
confinamiento más romeros a la más
amplia
más de un año después la pandemia en el
continente americano particularmente en
el conosur está lejos de mejorar
y en ningún lugar las infecciones son
más preocupantes que en américa del sur
donde los casos suben en casi todos los
países en miel
tanto brasil como argentina estuvieron
entre los 10 países del mundo con el
mayor número de nuevos contagios en la
última semana sin embargo las respuestas
de los gobiernos difieren en brasil que
registró el martes un nuevo récord de
víctimas mortales con cuatro mil
fallecimientos el gobierno sigue sin
imponer mayores restricciones
no vamos no aceptaremos esta política de
quedarnos en casa y cerrarlo todo el
virus no se irá
es el virus el virus como otros está
aquí para quedarse durante toda la vida
es prácticamente imposible erradicar lo
que haremos ese entonces y ya te habla
un fallo que ya
sin embargo los hospitales de las
principales ciudades se encuentran ya
desbordados desde hace semanas y el país
confirmó además la presencia de la
variante sudafricana del virus en su
territorio en sao paulo incluso los
hospitales improvisados están al límite
la ciudad más grande del país anunció
que comenzará a acabar 600 tumbas por
día
en cambio argentina anunció nuevas
medidas restrictivas para frenar los
brotes habrá toque de queda nocturno
durante tres semanas entre la medianoche
y las seis de la mañana se limitará el
uso del transporte público así como las
reuniones sociales y la actividad de
bares y restaurantes
estas medidas de cuidado son
indispensables para bajar la transmisión
estarán vigentes desde las 0 horas de
este viernes 9 de abril y durarán hasta
el 30 de abril venidero
argentina también registró un récord
histórico en este caso de nuevos
contagios con más de 22 mil infecciones
una cifra que augura un camino todavía
largo
y seguimos en américa latina porque en
ecuador el presidente de lenin moreno
reiteró retiro del cargo al ministro de
salud de mauro falconí ante el caso en
el caos en el proceso de vacunación
contra el coi 19 en la capital del país
y encargó a esa cartera al médico camilo
salinas salinas era el sexto ministro de
salud desde que moreno llegó a la
presidencia y el quinto desde que
comenzó la pandemia en ecuador en
febrero del año 2020
uruguay llegó a un nuevo récord de
positivos de coach 19 al registrar tres
mil novecientos treinta y cinco nuevos
casos y 40 fallecidos el país tuvo más
muertes en seis días de abril que en
todo el 2020 mientras que en colombia
bogotá y otras ciudades del país
entrarán en confinamiento estricto este
fin de semana
y seguimos con más noticias de la
pandemia en el mundo el ministerio de
sanidad polaco informó de 954 víctimas
mortales por corona virus en las últimas
24 horas la cifra más alta registrada en
el país es de que comenzó la crisis
sanitaria la elevada cifra de muertes se
reportaba bien acompañada de 27 mil 887
nuevos contagios mientras que el sistema
sanitario está trabajando al límite de
sus capacidades mientras que en india
hasta los casos diarios también son
alarmantes el país alcanzó 126 mil 789
nuevos casos en el último día el más
alto hasta el momento
en el último informe de amnistía
internacional publicado este miércoles
la organización humanitaria informa
sobre cómo ciertos países se han
aprovechado de la pandemia de ccoo y 19
para reprimir a los grupos minoritarios
las protestas y pasará por encima de los
derechos humanos incluso ha habido una
casi normalización de las medidas de
emergencia para restringir las
libertades civiles andrea maya nos
cuenta más en el siguiente informe
en 2020 el mundo entero fue sacudido por
una crisis sanitaria que aún no se ha
acabado pero algunas de las medidas
adoptadas para abordar la han tenido un
efecto devastador en la vida de millones
de personas en un análisis sobre la
situación en 149 países amnistía
internacional alerta que numerosos
gobiernos están instrumentalizando la
crisis sanitaria del cobi 19 para
avanzar en sus propias agendas
ching
descubrimos que en todo el mundo el
hobbit 19 ha amplificado las
desigualdades existentes
sting discrimination dentyne exacerbando
la discriminación y la desigualdad y las
personas más pobres en particular son
las más afectadas por el cob ido por la
respuesta a este virus
la mayoría de los que murieron ya
estaban entre los grupos vulnerables
wei wei y wing and demons fellner vulgo
la ong afirma en su reporte que los
gobiernos de medio oriente han usado las
medidas preventivas para hacer frente al
hobbit 19 como un pretexto para cometer
más abusos de los derechos humano
en áfrica la brutalidad de la policía de
nigeria ha provocado que las fuerzas de
seguridad maten a personas por
manifestar en las calles en europa
destacan las acciones del primer
ministro de hungría viktor orbán que
reformó el código penal para introducir
penas de hasta cinco años de cárcel por
divulgar información falsa sobre el
coronavirus en países como méxico
venezuela colombia y el salvador los
ataques a periodistas y defensores de
derechos humanos aumentaron dando lugar
a una furia social que fue contenida con
la excusa de la cuarentena por el coi 19
también con el pretexto de la pandemia
sostiene el informe
eeuu detuvo y deportó a medio millón de
migrantes y solicitantes de asilo además
las mujeres son las grandes afectadas en
esta crisis con un considerable aumento
de la violencia de género y violencia
intrafamiliar y cambiamos ahora la
información vamos hasta el reino unido
donde el gobierno condenó lo que
calificó como bullying del gobierno de
mianmar luego de que un agregado militar
tomara el control de la embajada de ese
país en londres y le impidiera la
entrada al embajador más temprano
conversamos con nuestra corresponsal
en ese país se nos reportó lo que se
conoce hasta el momento de la situación
en la embajada de mianmar en londres
veamos
buenos días continúan las protestas en
las afueras de la embajada de nilmar
aquí en el reino unido- en el centro de
londres desde las afueras de la embajada
el diplomático le ha pedido al gobierno
británico no reconocerá los bajador
designado por la junta ha dicho que en
febrero de este año hubo un golpe
militar en su país y que éste se ha
trasladado ahora aquí al centro de
londres ha dicho además que el staff de
la embajada los trabajadores han sido
amenazados por la junta de graves
castigos si no cooperan el embajador
tuvo que pasar la noche en su carro
porque como ya lo anunciaban no se le ha
permitido el ingreso a la sede
diplomática este embajador ha estado en
la mira podría decirse del gobierno de
la junta militar de mianmar porque ha
exigido la liberación de todos los
retenidos especialmente de la ex líder
andy sans souci
y también conversamos sobre el llamado
del gobierno irlandés a los líderes
políticos y comunitarios de irlanda del
norte para que trabajen en rebajar la
atención evitar muertos en la provincia
británica donde los disturbios de las
últimas noches sobre todo en la capital
belfast han causado daños materiales y
heridos esto fue lo que nos dijo
es una situación especialmente delicada
por las implicaciones que puede tener en
el proceso de paz de 1998 y el regreso
de la violencia como mencionas han sido
seis días de violencia de
enfrentamientos ininterrumpidos hasta el
momento 55 policías han resultado
heridos en estos enfrentamientos y un
número alto también de civiles la
jornada de hoy de anoche fue una de las
más violentas dado que los republicanos
e unionistas a los lealistas lanzaron
bombas molotov a la comunidad católica
republicana en lo que se conoce como los
muros de paz en belfast es tan grave la
situación que la asamblea regional de
irlanda del norte y su gobierno de
coalición del partido unionista de
irlanda y el sinn fein han sido
convocados de manera urgente para poder
encontrar una solución política a esta
delicada situación hoy jueves 8 de abril
el parlamento francés debate una
propuesta de ley sobre la eutanasia que
pretende establecer un derecho a un
final de vida libre y elegido pero los
diputados de la oposición
han presentado al menos tres mil
enmiendas para intentar bloquear el
proyecto de ley en efecto hace un debate
álgido en francia donde para muchos
enfermos terminales la única solución
para morir según su voluntad es irse al
extranjero nuestras reporteras
conocieron a uno de ellos así como
activistas que luchan por el derecho a
morir
alan cox sufre desde hace 35 años una
rara enfermedad incurable su vida está
limitada a las cuatro paredes de su
habitación
[Música]
soy prisionero de mi cama mi espacio
vital es muy limitado es mi vida ya no
es lo que era
cada día médicos enfermeras
fisioterapeutas y asistentes de salud se
turnan al lado de su cama para atender
sus necesidades
en 5 minutos le daré su pastilla en los
últimos dos años el estado de este
hombre de 58 años ha empeorado su dolor
es muy intenso cuando está sentado
incluso salir de su habitación en silla
de ruedas se volvió algo impensable con
la esperanza de conmover al presidente
escribió a emanuel makoun para pedirle
el derecho a morir a su manera y en su
país algo que la ley francesa prohíbe
actualmente ahora espera viajar a suiza
donde el suicidio asistido es legal para
los residentes extranjeros
no quiero morir como un vegetal
inconsciente de mi entorno es una
situación que la ex anestesista andiyán
conoce muy bien voluntaria de la
asociación por el derecho a morir con
dignidad acompaña regularmente a los
enfermos terminales que luchan por el
final apacible de su sufrimiento para
ella las leyes francesas al respecto son
anticuadas sedesol con terminal se
protege
pullmantur del crimen la sedación
paliativa puede durar días incluso
semanas mientras que con la muerte
asistida por el médico que proporciona
el medicamento que provocará la muerte
en cuestión de minutos todo el mundo
está informado los familiares y los
pacientes que son conscientes de su
entorno y pueden incluso cambiar de
opinión hasta el último momento y el uso
de sesos fue una opción a la que al
amigo que espera acceder pronto hasta
entonces seguirá luchando por el derecho
a morir para él y para quienes así lo
deciden
turquía aseguró que sigo el protocolo de
la unión europea cuando sentó a la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der layen en una posición secundaria
en la reunión que ella y el presidente
del consejo europeo charles michel
tuvieron el martes con el presidente
turco recep tayyip erdogán el llamado
sofá gay te abrió una polémica sobre el
trato reservado a la única mujer
presente en la reunión y dio lugar a un
cruce de declaraciones con turquía sobre
quién había defendido y definido el
protocolo para esta reunión
en otras palabras el acuerdo sobre el
donde sentarse fue diseñado para
satisfacer sus demandas y sugerencias y
punto no estableceríamos esto
explícitamente de no ser por las
acusaciones contra turquía pero vimos
que hay pronunciamientos incluso de alto
nivel como si esto lo hubiera hecho
turquía
lerner bar continuamos en europa en las
afueras de charlize en francia conocido
por su vino blanco afrutado y ácido
miles de velas fueron colocadas entre
los viñedos para tratar de protegerlos
de las fuertes heladas primaverales las
temperaturas cayeron hasta menos cinco
grados centígrados durante la noche en
regiones vinícolas como charlize borgoña
y burdeos lo que podría dañar los brotes
que ya están bien desarrollados una
fuerte obra de frío en abril del año
2017 dañó tanto los viñedos que la
producción anual de vino francés fue la
más baja en la historia de ese país y
con estas imágenes despedimos al
informativo continuar con nosotros que
tengo usted muy
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio de 2020 un millón más